Putin may have just won the war in
Ukraine let me explain Europe is
addicted to Russian natural gas that's
why Russia supplies Europe with 40 of
its energy with most of that coming
through its natural gas pipeline nor
stream one and Putin just shut off that
pipeline conveniently right before the
start of a very cold European winter
Vladimir Putin just turned up the
pressure Russian gas firm gas prom is
scheduled to switch off its largest
natural gas pipeline running to Germany
today not stream one pipeline shutdown
has left Europe On The Edge he's
unleashing one of the most powerful
economic weapons in his Arsenal Russia
will turn off the Taps of the nordstream
one pipeline which the country says is
necessary to carry out maintenance the
question is if it will switch it back on
right now Russia holds all the cards
so winter is coming and Europe's energy
Supply just dropped by almost half that
means if Europe doesn't come to the
negotiation table with Putin fast
there's going to be protests riots civil
unrest economic collapse maybe even
revolutions because Europeans won't be
able to heat their homes businesses
won't be able to afford electricity to
keep their doors open so businesses will
shut down which means people become
jobless which means people won't be able
to feed their families when the masses
can't feed their families that is when
the pitch Force come out that's when the
social unrest happens that's When
leaders get toppled or at the bare
minimum voted out of office which is
another way of saying that if Europe
doesn't bow down to Putin's terms the
entire European economy will literally
crumble and we already see it happening
Europe's Energy prices are already going
to the Moon right now as we speak take a
look around you and Society seems so
peaceful most of the time but what
people forget is that you're only one
meal away from a revolution Putin is
well aware of this and he's gonna use
all this pressure to get exactly what he
wants Europe is going to have to choose
do they hashtag Stanley Ukraine a
country that most Europeans have never
cared about before the war or do they
want to feed their families my name is
Jake Tran and we make documentaries on
money power war and crimes so that you
can see the world for what it really is
a giant game of acquiring power you
can't get out of this game either way so
instead of being a victim why not learn
to be a better player your parents
teachers friends Society will never
teach you any of this so we're going to
stay dangerous and let's get into it
when it comes to topics like Russia or
China it's super hard to find real
journalists who actually put their lives
on the line to get to the truth a great
way to tell how close a journalist is to
exposing the truth is to look at how
much they're being silenced intimidated
slandered that is why I have a ton of
respect for The Epic Times these guys
have had bugs set fire to their printing
presses because they criticize the
Chinese Communist party in Hong Kong
their journalists had been assaulted
like this woman who was beaten with a
baseball bat more than 10 times the
attack is believed to be orchestrated by
the CCP to intimidate them because The
Epic Times go so hard on China to expose
all the dark corrupt despicable stuff
they do that mainstream media won't
report on so if you like this channel
you're guaranteed to Love The Epic Times
they cover so many crazy stories that I
don't get to cover on this channel most
recently they came out with an 82-page
Special Report on the recession which
details into all the factors that are
driving the recession and they've got a
special offer for you guys you can get
two months of The Epic Times on all your
devices and the special report on the
recession for just one dollar with the
link below and hey you can always check
out the free articles first before you
subscribe so you have nothing to lose so
what are you waiting for support real
journalism by pausing the video and
getting too much for just one dollar by
going to Epic Times Jake Trent spelled
like this with a link below thanks to
the Epic test for sponsoring this video
[Music]
Europe's addiction to Russian gas
started innocently enough after the
Soviet Union fell many Saw reopening
trade with Russia as a means to
encourage diplomacy the start of a new
era especially in Germany even then
German leaders first promised themselves
that they would never let Russia Supply
more than 10 percent of their natural
gas Imports we don't want to become too
dependent on the Russians now would we
but taking a bite of the Apple was just
too tempting so once Europe got its
first taste of Glorious cheap Russian
gas there was no going back it was just
too affordable compared to anywhere else
but the cherry on top was the green
movement
[Music]
foreign
Trump went to Europe and gave them a
stark warning Germany will become
totally dependent
on Russian energy
if it does not immediately change course
do not become dependent on Russian gas
but because Trump is Trump they didn't
listen instead Germany laughed in his
face As Trump was talking so instead of
listening to Trump Europe decided to
listen to a 16 year old girl instead
Greta thunberg became the world's most
influential environmental activist while
she was still in high school she
organized and inspired student strikes
around the globe insisting that world
leaders weren't doing enough to stop a
climate crisis she grew insanely popular
not just because she was so young but
because of her very blunt and ruthless
public speaking style kind of like
Trump's style if you think about it so
three months after Trump spoke in Europe
Greta took the stage at the United
Nations climate change conference she
was not worried about the geopolitical
consequences of being too dependent on
Russia so her warning was the polar
opposite because you are too scared of
being unpopular you are not mature
enough
tell it like it is this is all wrong you
have stolen my dreams in my childhood
with your empty words how dare you how
dare you pretend that this can be sold
and you are still not matured enough to
tell it like it is
I don't want you to be hopeful I want
you to panic and panic they did the EU
responded by shutting down their nuclear
power plants abandoning coal and
investing in green energy like
hydroelectric wind and solar but even
then the economics for these green
Alternatives just wasn't there so Europe
was forced to make up the difference
with natural gas and since gas is
slightly cleaner than oil or coal that
seemed okay for the EU and who do they
go to for natural gas
Russia
[Music]
there's one thing Putin wants above all
else to keep Ukraine and other former
Soviet countries out of NATO forever
imagine if America's neighbors Mexico
and Canada wanted to get into a military
alliance with Russia the U.S would do
everything in its power to prevent them
from happening including violence and
intend issue that's because a deal like
that would open up the door for Russian
troops weapons and nuclear missiles to
be placed right outside America's
doorstep and this is exactly what the US
has been doing since the Soviet Union
fell even when they promised the
Russians they wouldn't that is what
Putin really wants no NATO for the
former Soviet countries especially
Ukraine the former Crown Jewel of the
Soviet Union so in January a month
before The Invasion Putin offered a
treaty with the U.S saying exactly that
no more NATO expansion on their doorstep
and as predicted the U.S turned him down
flat taking the moral High Ground about
not negotiating with bullies the fact of
the matter is we never were willing to
negotiate at all on those two demands at
all and instead we basically just
claimed they were a pretext by the
Russians for an invasion Putin couldn't
get what he wanted by playing fair so he
decided to take it up a notch he invades
Ukraine
he obviously thought he was going to be
successful and take over the whole
country but even The Invasion wasn't
successful he knew that with the eu's
dependency on his natural gas they'll
eventually have to cave in and give him
what he originally wanted Putin's
calculus is to go as far and as deep as
he can go so that he could eventually
negotiate himself back out in a way that
leaves him with what he originally
wanted in the first place I think this
just goes to show you that
if you're going to sort of engage in
proactive foreign policy you need to
make sure that domestically you don't
have any Achilles heels and Europe had a
massive Achilles heel which is energy
they're gonna have to take this much
more seriously uh going into next year
because they've enabled the Mad Men
[Music]
when Russian troops move towards Kiev
the EU also got on their moral High
ground and pulled out all their big
geopolitical guns as Putin predicted
Europe sanctioned Russia and put up a
good fight like Germany who refused to
certify Russia's newest pipeline
nordstream 2. it was Russia's brand new
shiny twin to nordstream one and without
Germany's approval it's just sitting
there completely unused and when the two
countries attempted peace negotiations
the West warned this was a bad idea
Europe insisted that Putin is not to be
negotiated with under any circumstances
while somehow not thinking that Russia
would use the only card they had
[Music]
one pipeline shut down old stream
pipeline shut down tonight there is
nothing in the pipeline from Russia
Russia is shutting down gas supplies
from a major pipeline to Europe for the
next three days
[Music]
now Europe is set to freeze both
literally and economically yet no EU
countries are changing course instead
the EU is telling citizens to suck it up
and save electricity whatever we do one
thing is for sure we have to save
electricity but we have to save it in a
smart way so what we have to do is
flatten the Curve and avoid the peak
demands we will propose a mandatory
Target for reducing electricity use at
peak hours or possibly threatening jail
time if people turn their heat above 66
degrees Fahrenheit but winter is fast
approaching and things are going to get
a lot worse and no it's not as simple as
Europe switching over to other energy
sources before winter they do not have
the infrastructure to switch from
natural gas to something like oil and
time you can't convert oil into natural
gas to heat people's homes it's
impossible structurally right now in the
time frame that it's needed so when the
protests come when the civil unrest
comes when politicians get voted out of
office we'll see who breaks first
Germany will probably be the first to
break because while Europe got 40
percent of its natural gas from Russia
Germany was getting more than half of
theirs from Russia that Russian end game
is essentially the following which is
that Germany will probably be first to
capitulate but it'll be a combination of
the United States and Europe who
negotiate some kind of a settlement and
if a deal isn't made the results could
be catastrophic there's going to be
significant writing and civil unrest in
Europe and um and there will be a
significant significant economic effect
the economy will be shattered economies
will be shattered and people will be
really unhappy as this video being
edited Russia announced a mandatory
draft of 300 000 civilians to fight his
war in Ukraine is
so it looks like the Russian military
might be on its last leg so the only
question that remains is who will last
longer Europe without natural gas or
Russia in Ukraine regardless what all
this really shows is that the masses
today are complete hypocrites
a few months ago it was either you stand
with Ukraine or you're a Putin loving
fascist but the minute the minute the
public feels any amount of actual pain
the minute their lives are
inconvenienced you'll see that it's just
all talk everyone supposedly hates
Amazon yet they still shop on Amazon
everyone hates Walmart yet they still
shop at Walmart everyone hates poon
until they don't know where their next
meal is coming from
foreign
being the target of blackmail is a nasty
experience whether the blackmailer is
Russia or just one person and one person
that was a master at blackmail was every
jebsty he understood that today the best
way to Blackmail a powerful leader is to
get compromising footage of them with
underaged girls once you had that these
powerful men became your female dogs and
it appears that he was probably some
sort of intelligence agent as well
because every time he got in trouble
with the law he would be magically set
free until one day his secret protectors
decided that he was no longer worth the
risk and we all know what happened then
but the problem is going into the life
of every Jeb stain in all his exploits
would definitely get demonetized on
YouTube so we've released a private
documentary available right now to
members of this channel it goes over all
the gruesome disgusting details and so
far members have been loving it all you
have to do to watch this private
documentary right now is to click that
join button below once you join you'll
get instant access to our other
exclusive documentaries as well like CIA
black sites MK Ultra the bin Laden
papers and more these are the things
they should be teaching you in school
but aren't and unlike University we're
not going to charge you thousands of
dollars nope you can get access to all
of this for just five dollars a month
and there's a refund policy too unlike
most YouTube memberships so if you join
and you don't think it's worth it email
us within your first month of joining
for the first time and we will
personally refund you for your first
month after your first month there is no
refund click that join button below to
watch now
[Applause]
so what do you guys think was this a
genius move on puta's part or a really
dumb move on the eu's part for not
realizing that he would do this let me
know in the comments below we're posting
on Tick Tock again at jtran33 that's the
handle right now so that'll be linked
below and yeah you can follow me on
Instagram jaketrad but that is going to
wrap it up thanks for being part of the
watch the end Club stay dangerous out
there and I will see you guys in the
next one
thank you